one of the main reasons i reached out to
you and asked you to come on the podcast
is well first of all i found out that
you lived in japan which is great very
convenient for us because we only let
in-person guests come on yeah uh in two
obviously there was some massive recent
news yes uh at the time of recording uh
this will be published a lot later um
and i kind of want to get into the most
recent history and obviously if people
who are
sorry
come on
sorry sorry i'm sorry every time we say
christopher gina is like
funny it must be like whiplash
um you know like we said there was a
very big news and uh i guess let's talk
about the very recent his question sorry
um
uh about it because i i think the
viewers who don't know anything will be
intrigued uh or viewers who do know will
want a little recap maybe yeah um so
what would you say is like the very
recent where where it began i guess or
whether
or whatever if you will
so this all started at the end of july
of this year when a certain phone call
was linked with like a discord uh voice
chat it was like between chris and a
certain female party
a real female part a real female by the
way an actual female who was actually
obsessed with chris right that's that's
that's a different female okay okay all
right there was someone who genuinely
like wanted to be with chris yeah he was
in this group
yes yes yes there was but this is a
different this is a very
disgusting female trolls and female and
they were chatting away and chris
revealed very casually
how
their recent
development in their relationship with
uh with their mother was going
and how it started and how
when did this development start i guess
june or july of this year as far as we
know right yeah chris was yeah exploring
their mother's body
and um
this is actually sickening it's so
disgusting it's so disgusting
quite crazy but i remember when it
started everyone's like please say psych
like please say this is the joke i
remember that even the kiwi farms
members were like no no i'm sure there's
a mistake yeah um
what was originally leaked was a four
and a half minutes
edit of the call which was very heavily
edited uh which which originally removed
all mentions of the female party in the
call so he didn't hear it at all so it
sounded very fake and edited so i
thought maybe like they're being
stitched together
to make it sound like that but no later
at another point like a nine minute call
was leaked with the with the full
contacts and no chris was actually doing
this apparently i was i was hoping that
that chris was like astral projecting
and like
maybe in their mind having having
intercourse with the with their mother
in quickville just one of the justified
in any way that they would not really be
real
yeah i know i saw that argument quite a
bit when the news first broke out
because you know the whole thing of
chris you know with the whole quickville
thing being you know almost in this
delusional world right so i think the
biggest argument was that they just
imagined that they you know did stuff
with their mother but in reality we have
no proof kind of thing other than this
call obviously but yeah yeah chris was
talking about how at first
she said no
and
but then apparently uh chris
satisfied her in a way that their father
never could
it's it's you can't make this up it's so
[ __ ] i actually feel physically sick
yeah i do i feel like it's disgusting
this is like the most disgusting episode
like every bone in my body like i i
think this is the worst and most like i
definitely feel we need to put a
disclaimer at the beginning of this
episode yeah yeah because yeah and and
what's more messed up is that this
all came out of chris's mouth as well
like this wasn't paraphrasing or
anything this was like
like their voice this is how proud i
think chris sounded very disturbed
and how almost
like happy
they were was very disturbing yeah and
it was just you know for every time you
you feel that chris understands
social norms or understands the
situation there's just another one that
slaps you in the face where you're like
chris has no understanding of what the
[ __ ] is right or wrong i feel
like i feel like i've heard serial
killer stories that are less disturbing
than some of the stuff i've heard right
right now like this is this is just
going like so many stages beyond what is
even like
comprehendable of what a human mind can
do you know it's uh
it's if someone wrote this in a story
they would be like unrealistic yeah i
know this is [ __ ] this is so stupid
no one would ever do this yeah and it's
just like it's just so sad and then also
uh chris later did is chris currently in
prison or jail currently in jail yes
because rightly so yeah incest charges i
believe for incest charges yes because
over 200 people called the local police
department after that call was leaked
and um chris
and their mother were actually first
separated you know um chris wentz chris
had to find some some other form of
accommodation for for a while while
their mother was being checked in in the
health center
and um yeah chris was at a hotel and
there were lots of people outside the
hotel recording and taking pictures and
like like like waiting for us for a
celebrity to come to come out of the
door it's disgusting
immediately found where yeah they were
staying right it's just disgusting these
trolls doing this like what's wrong with
you like what this is not something to
like try and get a scoop off like this
is just tragic
and then and then the police came around
and chris was arrested publicly in front
of everyone and then chris said that the
merge was happening like like the merge
of dimensions of cartoon and reality
were happening and i was like chris
doesn't realize
what they're getting into yeah i mean i
actually
because you know when i saw the news
break out and i think there was a guy
who was live streaming the entire yeah
yeah yes it's a it's another lol cow
yeah yeah so one of the locals was live
streaming the arrest of chris
these guys seemed so pathetic oh yeah
absolutely pathetic human being
but like because like the guy was
shouting at chris like like a [ __ ]
paparazzi yeah being like how do you
feel like what what what's going on in
your mind right now and of course you
know chris is just like smiling very
jovial throughout this whole what's so
disturbing is that throughout that
entire time where chris is talking about
you know the dimensions merging and that
they have you know like sonichu and rose
chew in their presence or whatever they
were saying
the entire time again they were smiling
like they have no idea
how much [ __ ] there is like yeah and
does did chris understand what being
arrested i don't i don't even think
chris understood what was happening
also i believe they were like plugging
their channel as well while he was well
yes i think yeah they were plugging the
channel
something like that yeah they're
plugging their channel a lot of places
it's just like what
what are you guys doing there was so
much wrong with that live stream yeah
yeah
i kind of just want to bleach my ears
like it was really hard to sit through
the footage but yeah my god it was
it wasn't yeah it was insane yeah as
[ __ ] as it is it's also super [ __ ]
the sheer amount of people that are
trying to just milk this for content
yeah um a lot of people just you know
were making really terrible clickbait
videos that were like 10 minutes it
didn't
include anything and we just just put
chris's name in the title because it was
a hot topic of course and i believe you
actually went on you announced a hiatus
yes so this happened yeah i was actually
originally playing hiatus anyway after
part 60 came out but in light of these
events i thought 59 is close enough so i
released 59 i guess as scheduled maybe a
day after
the arrest or or so and then i did a
hiata stream saying i'm going on break
until next year see you around yeah this
is because of the the yeah because i
because i want things to cool down i
don't want to take advantage of the
situation so i'll you know i'll back
away for a bit yeah i mean props to you
it'd be very easy to be like you know
what this is probably the highest search
terms the best seo for chris chan right
now you know it's everywhere every video
about christians getting a million views
i could just pump it out right now and
get two mil but oh yeah props to you man
i i i do and yeah that's that's big boy
move right there yeah oh yeah you want a
lot of respect points from me for doing
that uh this must been a tough call i'm
sure a lot of people like no release the
next part tell us about all the details
actually most people were very
understanding really really yeah
actually that was very surprised i mean
i guess from the seriousness of the
situation yeah when it happened you know
did you get like a barrage of messages
and emails i did yes
they they're slow down for for now yeah
but i'd probably get two or three
hundred twitter dms saying i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
it's like sorry for your loss it's like
a personal loss like a like a family
member or something
geez yeah is this the end then is do you
think this is the end of the story
it's very it's a very quiet part of the
story at least right but um
yeah since chris is in prison now or in
jail actually awaiting trial in
september i believe yeah uh there's
nothing coming out of chris
not nothing at all so it's very quiet
it's just speculation and discussion i i
do hope the because in courthouses in
america you can just turn up can't you
if you're you can turn up but i believe
there's laws against recording yeah you
can't record yeah you can
you can write an account of what happens
i somehow have the feeling that we'll
get some audio recording i somehow have
a feeling that the trolls are gonna find
a way they're going to find a way yeah
yeah it's going to be so sad you know
this is already disgusting enough last
thing you want it's like 20 trolls in
the courthouse just like giggling away
watching this all go down
i don't know it's
don't be that guy this is this is the
why this whole thing i say is a suspect
because anyone involved with this in
most what in most capacity
is a piece of [ __ ] like both parties are
justified you're good you're good
i i you know i there are a lot of people
who are out there trying to take
advantage in any single way they can get
a quick mark yeah exactly exactly um
yeah it's just man it's just nuts the
more i think about it i'm just like this
this would be the greatest told
fictional story of all time and then you
remember horus nothing is fictional
about this i think the most horrible
thing about this is that is this is real
yeah this is exactly actually
like this is this actually happened yeah
it's happened
in real life and it's just so well
documented
um and it's just like all these events
when you when you hear them separately
they sound like you know like that would
be the worst moment of somebody's life
right yeah or somebody's like one of
those things and to think that that all
came from one person yeah that's why i
think you know people say most
documented person history i don't think
that's correct i think it's the most
embarrassing documentation of someone in
history right no one has taken as many
hours as chris no one has self-given
that many hours the sheer amount of
disturbing stuff that has been
self-documented yeah you know serial
killers haven't reached this level of
[ __ ] up stuff yeah you know we've had
serial killers with more like class than
some of the stuff that chris has been
doing which is boring to say yeah
honestly you know and i i again like the
whole situation is very sad yeah um i've
never wanted somebody to lose access to
the internet more than chris at many
points yeah yeah i mean you just
sometimes you see people online and you
just think you should not have any kind
of internet presence at all and i think
this is just
the worst example of just like what
everything that can go wrong and
everything that has gone wrong yeah when
i found it wrong when i found out that
chris had a twitter i was like oh no
this oh you know i feel like chris is
well before this before this drama
happened recently chris had been pretty
tame online yeah um chris today i think
it actually commented in one of our
videos
what i believe so really
when we spoke about chris on trash taste
he's serious i believe chris had
actually commented on it and a very
normal comment right and chris had been
pretty
chill i'd say it was pretty calm about
most things we know yes
until the [ __ ] storm happened it was the
calm before the storm